greetings from podcast Ville it's the
25th it's official it's Christmas Day so
this is Christmas and what have you done
the church what's happening now is
brought to you by manscaped listen the
manscape is the best and below-the-belt
Gruman it's Christmas Day
you're showing up like Santa with two
big sacks full of holiday cheer and
yum-yum juice for everybody what if you
did what if it looks like a cave and
I'll send you remind people of those
little 12 tight kids look when they
walked into the dungeon this is what I'm
saying it they got a thing called a lot
more 2.0 for a reason they threw away
the UMP 1.0 and upgraded the trimmer
with a skin-safe technology so you're
always looking sharp down there around
the nut sack and around the body stick
you know I'm saying for you Momo's in
the back it means a woman ick or snag in
nut sack you could cut your little nut
sack anxiety free okay so do me a favor
those Church listeners get up to 20% off
your first order when you use promo code
church at manscape comm order the
perfect package which you talked about
at the end of the show and they're gonna
throw on a free travel bag it's the
coolest thing you ever seen it's got an
indoor zipper people always ask me I'm
for joy what do you hide the goods at
well talk to me later and I'll tell you
but for right now go to manscape comm
use promo code Church CH you are CH and
get 20% off your first daughter listen
with manscape you keep your nutsack nice
and polished I'm saying number two I
also talk to you about honor in the same
way on it's got the Alpha brain look on
a percent money back guarantee and right
now they're running a contest you buy on
it alpha brain they send your raffle
ticket you get the raffle ticket you
when you get the whole lot of experience
listen you go to the steakhouse that
giving you two grand in cash you get to
jump up and down with professional to
give you year supply on it it just
doesn't stop go to on it comrade now and
get your bottle alpha brain and cut this
[ __ ] it's your lucky 2020 is the way to
go
kick this mealy get this day started
merry Christmas to all you guys and your
families thank you very much for
listening I know for a fact that for
some people you know 60% of people
listen for this podcast and probably
jumping up and down right now they won't
even listen to this podcast by Monday
but there's a lot of people 40% of you
that need this podcast this time of the
year is the best time of the year for
everybody you know and I get it I get it
I'm not I have a family I have a wife I
have a kid I have dear friends but it
seems like you're missing something when
you're not around your family or a
family members gone it doesn't feel like
Christmas anymore but it still is it
still is you know last week I did the
one-man show at The Comedy Store and I
covered a certain time in my life in 93
to 95 and I'll never forget Christmas in
94 Christmas in 94 will always stick
with me forever for a thousand reasons I
made something out of nothing I woke up
with three dollars in my pocket and
stole the Christmas tree and got on an
$80 cash and got Chinese food and stole
a bike and made Jackie my first sibling
that was the last time we saw each other
but I still remember her leaving that
night and me feeling like death I had I
remember putting up the decorations a
duct tape I don't even have money and I
like Christmas tape I had that little
stuff you put it on your apartment I
don't know you know the glove this stuff
I put it up with duct tape I got Chinese
food delivered because there's the only
people that are open on on Christmas Day
and we had a nice day together I had a
thousand gifts for her and a bike and
this and that this I remember her
leaving and me breaking down like I
usually didn't it was Christmas so
there's no one to go do family or
anything and for a minute there I'm not
saying I felt suicidal but I just didn't
feel good
you don't feel that data you don't
Christmas Day some people get up man
it's not Christmas day for them
I can imagine especially after going up
as a kid and having presents under the
tree and yeah because Hanukkah the whole
week it's a little different it's it's
not Christmas Day you know for some
people and I'm really sorry you feel
this way it's something that the
holidays kind of bring him down we were
gonna take this week off but like I said
no no no no no we need to talk about
this we've talked about this and why you
feel this way and it was so weird that
night when she left with her mother I
sat there and you know it's just looking
around I was probably getting ready to
make the call to get a package you know
you might to go thing when things got
bad a package would make her feel better
and somewhere along that I remember
looking up looking at this little
apartment maybe the size of this office
and going what do I feel bad about you
know I think I was getting dressed head
to a party or something like that Sammy
invited me to a Christmas party because
you're never really alone on Christmas
unless you really want to be somebody
always reaches out and says hey man you
want to stop by and as bad as you feel
as bad as you feel you stopped and you
got a bottle and you get an apple pie or
whatever once you get to that place
something about that place you'll see
the magic of Christmas and the magic of
Christmas not like somebody on the phone
yes and I go listen leader good for
Christmas they said I don't know you're
like no what you're gonna do you gonna
sit by yourself ghost what if there's a
problem
swing by hangul you have no idea what a
hug from the six-year-old the do for you
they'll change your whole perspective on
Christmas you know like for some people
it's just hitting a table and going
looking up and looking at strangers
you've been in that position on a
Christmas day where you pop your head up
and you looking at all strangers and you
ask yourself how do I even get here well
University carried again the universe
takes carry as much if you don't think
it's taking carry the universe is taking
carry I've been you know you know you
know what Christmas is on the road Lee
you know it's like to go out on the road
and Christmas Wawa waaahh it's on a
Thursday and you're in Ohio so you do
Tuesday and Wednesday and Christmas
daddy you pretty much stay in your room
and watch the parade of roses there's no
budget for you to fly this Imam or to
see your brothers nothing so it's one of
those Christmases where you by yourself
I did four or five of those on the road
where you're there you're in [ __ ]
Indiana it's you and the headliner on
Christmas Day and he's got a friend in
town and it's you in this apartment and
you're sitting there going Jesus what is
my life become you know and all sudden
something stops and says wait a second
you're doing what you would wanted to do
this is part of the bargain so you get
up off the couch you go down to the
nearest Walmart that's open til 1:00
there's a bunch of old senior citizens
they got dead three days away from the
grave they're happy to see and they're
welcoming you and you're going you buy a
dollar Christmas tree you buy a bunch of
treats you go back to the house and you
watch Christmas program and then you eat
your little snacks and you smoke you a
couple of joints and you take a couple
sips of new beer and it wasn't all that
bad
just by stepping out of the house and
making you see some guy that's got three
days left on his cool life saying merry
Christmas to you that does something to
you all these little things do something
for you and that's why I don't want you
to number one rule for tomorrow today is
I don't want you to be alone you spent
some time with uncle Joey get out out
somebody invited you someone or even if
it was just a watch again cuz you never
know what could happen when
watching the game whatever's there
football games ma there's gonna be some
college bowl game the best Lakers are
playing the clip is there's something
going on you know do not be alone but
back to 94 I'm sitting there I'm crying
and all of a sudden something happened
that made me open my calendar like that
I don't know what it was to see what I
had the week ahead I've always had a
calendar and I'm about having like three
spots that we like like having like
three real spots a two guest sets of
clubs and like one paid gig and it all
swirled that me then that I was grateful
I had never been grateful before you
have no idea how being grateful on
Christmas day makes you feel because
most of us are sitting there thinking
about what we don't have and you really
have to think about what you do have you
know there's a guy that's part of the
church family since day one
I met him to Rogen and I don't know if
he knows this he inspires me hold on yo
yo mercy
you want to crinkle that paper a little
more you want to crinkle that paper a
little more all right then Jesus Christ
yo I'm over here trying to do a party
and you're bringing papers and stuff you
say I gonna deal with is what happens
you know I'm school and you gotta drag
your daughter with you but I don't mind
I'm gonna have with me all day I'm gonna
take it to a couple places get around
the house if the mama breather there's a
national tormenta mom at some point I
gotta get it to a park to do a thousand
little zip recruiter things and go back
and forth on the monkey bars him not
she'll be jumping up and down on that
clay it's a bad energy day but you in
the middle of all this once I became
grateful Christmas has changed you know
Joey and I and Lea were talking about
mindsets when you do things you don't
want to do it it all changes the
depending on how you go into it listen
going through the gym sucks
you go into it next thing you know you
look at the clock you have for you
they're mixing they look at the clock
and the guys going alright we got
already last minutes let's turn up the
heat a little bit you're out of that and
you were like what was so bad about that
you know it's it's it's getting yourself
there I don't even know how we got on
the topic you were saying something
about someone from Rogen for what
someone from Rogen someone you met
through Rogen inspires you yeah and his
name is crying Michael Michael turned
her and Michael I met Michael crying at
a Rogen concert and his kids in a
wheelchair I don't know what his
condition is or whatever god bless him
the guy doesn't give up she's walking
now yeah he's [ __ ] walk you think the
guy's not grateful so next time you City
you're sitting there in pity of yourself
because you lost your job your
girlfriend dumped you she got pregnant
by a different part of Rican you know
what call the complain Micah's page and
see if there's any pity in his page see
if there's once has there been pity on
his [ __ ] page see if there's a
picture of him all mangled up no it's
pictures of him walking it's pictures of
them with no shirt on it's written then
he shows up the shows are [ __ ] for
you [ __ ] that are waiting for
the next coming of life this guy's in
the wheelchair get his dead dick sucked
what are you doing what are you doing
you know you think about it you really
have to look at something like current
Michael to really appreciate life and go
what am I doing with my life this guy is
in a wheelchair and he's walking around
like like Jesus number one Jesus was
hitting those people in the head and
they started walking so I look at that
guy there and I go what am i doing my
life I gotta go make people laugh and
I'm depressed I gotta go make people
laugh and I have anxiety I'm scared I
mean you have to this and I'm not saying
this in a negative way but why you
sitting there falling and pity for
yourself on Christmas there's somebody
else that that's enough that's Anna 10th
yeah that's somebody else that's Ana
shelter there's somebody else that's
under observation for psychiatric
reasons for whatever it may be and here
you are sitting in your apartment
watching the Rose Bowl parade like you
know thinking that thinking about
pulling a Chris Cornell no no no no no
no no no no no looking at them a
different angle look at it from how
grateful you are to have what you have
your mother might be an out gay what at
least you've got a mother you don't see
me gone in my mother's house so whatever
you might be thinking that Joey's going
to birth crises or Tom Segura is and
they're gonna be jumping up and down you
got your mother I don't have a mother so
we all have our little personal Viet
Nam's but from December 23rd to January
6 they all go away
listen what did i do put you in debtors
prison what did I do put you in jail cuz
it's gonna evict you they can't listen
be grateful for what you have and
Christmas and the rest of the everybody
you know why I'm grateful on this day
because I'm I know I'm getting one day
closer to a new start
listen just like you I'm not fond about
Kristen if you don't see me with Sam
pants on I got a daughter that don't
like Christmas
she don't like Santa Claus she's she
don't ask to take pictures of Santa
Claus I got a picture home when she was
two making sure I'm between her and
[ __ ] Santa cause that's how much you
ain't Santa Claus I didn't teach you to
hate the Santa Claus I never even used
the post love Santa Claus she wrote
Santa Claus a letter she talks about
Santa but she who said [ __ ] Don
is this all and that's just the way life
is sometimes she keeps that dude far far
far away from her and like I was saying
Christmas day for me is knowing one
thing once Christmas comes I know I'm 3
or 4 days away from
hatching my plan for the new year you're
unhappy and aventure 2024 you should be
a new business you're opening up a new
business
how is sadly you you ever gonna run to
the bank and you get the paperwork
approved and you find the location and
you got a deal with the landlord and you
got to build the bathroom because
midgets gotta use a [ __ ] bathroom and
you got to deal with the sign yeah yeah
and finally that day has come that
you're gonna do the grand opening soft
party well guess what
that's a 2020 is you're getting a chance
to open up your own business think about
that no matter how bad Christmas feels
no matter how bad of a year you had this
year no matter how good of a year you
have this year think about this 2020
you're opening up a whole new restaurant
oh my god it might get excited I got
gogo girls while you eat meatball
while you're eating the hands like a
woman I'm gonna come by and cut that
pube and throw them in your face that's
the idea I got for a new restaurant I'm
bullshitting you people I'm trying to
say to you is you have a new chance to
be a new you for 2020 that thing you've
been thinking about doing that's been on
the back burner for the last year it's
time to execute it so today and tomorrow
you walk down the CVS you get yourself
the cheapest notebook they have and you
write down this business you started
this business that's called you if your
name is John Smith it's the John Smith
and I'm the CEO of my company how is it
gonna be different this year
well maybe John Smith that's a high
paying job that makes 120,000 a year
with full Benenson
maybe John Smith is happy with what he
has but made you be John Smith just
wants a little more he's in a
relationship he's got a kid he's married
he wants a little bit more out of life
as you get older if you don't want more
you're [ __ ]
when you're 38 one day you're gonna wake
up and go you know what when I was six I
wanted to play the [ __ ] flute in a
band and you're gonna go on in to that
flute and who's got a flute Club around
here and my neighbourhood and you're
gonna sit around with six other
potential [ __ ] and play the [ __ ] flu
until you're happy I'm not saying you're
gay what I'm saying is that you're gonna
go play the flute or the guitar because
that's what human nature is wanting more
there's nothing wrong with more anything
more
so John Smith could be a guy that's
making hundred twenty grand a year with
full benefits but there's something
missing from his life because it's
better to want and to have see we get
lied to we're gonna go to college and
then we're gonna find the life of our
dreams and you all you jerk-offs watch
office space and all these movies and
you think that it's just a [ __ ] party
that you go there and then have to win
you get drinks and it's Michelob time
what's that no one maker's mark the
Puerto Rican with his mother everybody
knows polar Ricans drink Colt 45 knock
it off would [ __ ] make this bark not
commercial you know everybody thinks
that this is gonna be a life Lee and I
have had this conversation we've seen
college students around this sort of
graduated and think it's this TV show
it's not it's not it's a challenge a lot
of you guys are college graduates and
you're sitting there thinking about your
next meal because that piece of paper
didn't do dick now it needs to come into
balance is that piece of paper that
thing got called
good old American common sense and
that's what's going on with John Smith
John Smith knows he's making a ton of
money for his [ __ ] company he sits in
a goddamn cubicle all day but he wants
just a little bit more out of life just
a little bit more so Johnson is gonna
take a shot this year he's gonna take a
class that's three hours a week on a
[ __ ] gemology and then once the class
is over he's gonna meet somebody in that
stupid class who has the same needs and
interest that he has in the same
position and maybe they got a boot that
a [ __ ]
a gem convention to twice a year to
start off with this is what 2020 should
be meaning to you right now oh it's a
new decade I don't give a [ __ ] if it's a
new decade to me it's just another
[ __ ] day in a new year and it means
another day in a new year that you get
the chance to do what you really really
really really really really wanted to do
not what your parents wanted not what
you're cutting in the direction [ __ ] all
that what you really want to do what is
it that's gonna add to my life or how am
I gonna change we have so many different
options for 2020 it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous how good 2020 looks right now
and I got nothing going on it's not like
you don't see me shoot the Netflix
special you don't see me and no [ __ ]
selling a lifestyle nothing I just know
that I'm gonna be a better person and I
know that I'm gonna be a better stand-up
comic I'm gonna keep going after that
[ __ ] store and I'm gonna keep getting
better and [ __ ] better and keep
writing I'm starting to write into our
you know we do have hopefully the book
will come out this year
I've been working on putting together a
vocal book whatever the [ __ ] you audio
book audiobook because listen with as
far as the writing is concerned you got
a better chance of [ __ ] Jesus coming
down and raping you or this big cuz it
takes me three pair days to write a
paragraph it's a great paragraph but it
takes three days at the end of the time
at the end of the week it's the law of
diminishing returns by the time you get
Joey Diaz his life story Joey Diaz will
die and whoever replaces his [ __ ]
life will be right this life story and
even though you can't write it so I said
forget all that we're gonna switch it up
so yeah I got I have things I'm looking
forward to doing I don't have all the
opportunities lot of other guys have but
I got one opportunity the only one
that's ahead of me and that's being fun
here what can I do to be funny
go deeper into my gut say what I deeper
feel my heart
and learn how to transfer to a paper we
don't think I'm excited about 2020 right
now you're out of your mind and not you
know we think excitement and action is
financial it's a lucrative it's we're
gonna be at bars dressed in white like
Don Johnson by him no no no no no I'm
talking like my personal growth is the
best feeling you could ever have in your
life personal growth knowing that you're
going for something with everything you
got yeah you got your day job I get it
but guess what what do you do at night
you talk to the kids for two minutes you
talk to your [ __ ] wife for two minutes
who if you like me after ten minutes you
want to stab them in the neck anyway cuz
you got from seven to ten on this couch
doing nothing say forget it two nights a
week I gotta go do something I'm gonna
take money out of my savings I'm gonna
take a [ __ ] class at the local
college something to tour 2020 should
add something else to your [ __ ] life
something else that you want to do what
else do you want to do there's gotta be
something else you want to do beside be
a Mook and I don't listen I'm not even
talking about that I'm just talking
about look at 2020 is a new beginning
feel like be grateful for what you have
hey you know what man I got a thousand
regrets and I wish I had a thousand
things but you know what sometimes it's
better to wanted to have it's funny
again not putting anybody down here I'm
not saying anything off-color I watched
the Eddie Murphy on that's enough that's
enough I didn't watch the whole episode
cuz that's not gonna happen
I haven't really heard anything that it
was groundbreaking and what I did see
was a lot of smoke and mirrors I'm not
saying nothing bad about Eddie at all I
know I know means well it's funny that
was one point I saw this on Facebook of
Tracy Morgan and Chris Rock and Eddie
and Dave Chappelle walking on stage
and Chappelle put a cigarette out he lit
it and he goes is that allowed and he
goes no and the audience got a big laugh
and I thought that was cute you know I
thought the whole thing was great but do
you want me to tell you something and
this is the funniest [ __ ] thing in
the world I wouldn't want to be one of
those guys have you paid me like I
wouldn't want to have to be shipped up I
don't I didn't get into calmly to be
that guy
is there another comedian who you would
like Charlie go if I can have their
career that then I'd be happy or is it
just personal to you luckily I really
admire Doug Stanhope scurry R and Andrew
Schultz his career and I paddled it from
both of their careers
I think that my special days have come
to an end I have come to that I think
that I'd really just want to work on my
live act you know I don't ever have
aspirations I'm all alone wait live show
like I've never watched them so I have
no aspirations if it was Johnny Carson
and somebody would come to me and say
they want you to do six minutes clean
for him I would do it but that stuff you
know somebody told me a very interesting
thing you had that and you know you know
me guys I'm raised humanum Santeria and
Catholic but I love a couple things in
the bullish religion
I really do and a and a dear friend of
miles brother said to me write something
write it down seven times what you
really want and I did it I did at the
end that I still come to I got really
high and I wrote it down just to see
what the answer was and after seven
times ain't got shorter and shorter and
shorter the other night my daughter was
on celeb
[Music]
called ABC something ABC not the kid one
that you see commercialize merci merci
thank God she don't know that I can let
a fire and an [ __ ] she wasn't no
that's what I would do that she's my
beautiful little daughter but it's some
maybe she something goes my grades and
she I let her use my computer and I her
dad I was watching World News Tonight
like didn't know she had just got stuck
in and 20 minutes later dad like go home
and she goes that I oughta put this into
a file on this app this kids app had a
page to write a letter Santa Claus on it
no I knew she had written a letter the
Santa Claus but then she she wanted a
double check he got it
so she wrote them on the internet on the
[ __ ] cloud and when I read the letter
I gotta taste something I had to get up
and wipe my tears from my face she wrote
dear Santa I've been a good girl is she
ever really tried I've made a few
mistakes at this point I'll take
whatever you give me I'll take anything
that you give me but what I really want
for Christmas is to be happy this is
really this is the mind of a
six-year-old and this is what we [ __ ]
forget guys that's it that's it do you
know what I felt like when I read that
that I took a page out of a six year
olds like that's it
last month Sunday night when I got home
from my segments at the store and I did
my closing arguments for they had my
notebook I wrote that it's Sunday and it
doesn't matter if they bomb Japan young
come Cola sends a missile over here if
they impeach Trump nothing really
matters it's [ __ ] Christmas it's
great
it's time to be happy it's time to all
that [ __ ] that you put throughout the
hating your boss and being mad at this
person all that stuff goes away and let
me tell you some it took me 56 years to
realize that I'm no [ __ ] genius but
I'm telling you right now about four
years ago it came to me it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter all the hard
work and all the suffering you put in
this year ends on the 22nd or 23rd you
have to put your mind somewhere else you
have to put your mind on the good things
that happened
yeah but Joey you can't died yeah but
Joey you ain't a bag of dicks and
Lolly's yeah Joey you missed the flight
in Atlanta dawg I had a thousand
shortcomings this year but there was
shortcoming I didn't have I ruined dude
20 30 minutes you know I'll tell you
what shortcomings I didn't have I didn't
give up on my health I had a lot of
shortcomings but there's a lot of things
I didn't do I didn't stop being who the
[ __ ] I was knew who the [ __ ] I believe
in I could care less about the cancer
culture or whatever the culture you got
the only culture I got is the culture
that comes up in between my [ __ ] legs
that looks like yoga but it tastes like
death milk so that's the only culture I
think about but I really want you to
think about this [ __ ] why you sitting
there today after you listen to a few
podcasts forget about everything else
man it's about what you have and it's
about three days from now when your
[ __ ] plan gets hatched can you
imagine that Justin you've been dreaming
about three years that you've been
scared of trying because you might fail
Oh gets a [ __ ] you know many times you
gotta fail before you anything if you
try it the first time it's just gonna
flourish that's a problem with people
we've become too we think that after one
or two tries that that's it my life is
done [ __ ] your life
and you got 19 more failures before you
even move another inch on this [ __ ]
field this football field we're playing
on you're trying to move it's an inch
and again you watch games you think you
go in there and stand mind where the
quarterback is will actually drop and
throw a ball ten yards no you can't you
can't the first three times they give
you the boy you have to put your head
down and move forward and you just go on
for the game of inches so right now if
you're the positioning you think in your
life that you're playing in the game of
inches this is what it is some people in
the playing the game of six inches some
people are playing the game of feet I
play in the game of inches and I'll
never ever change that
no disrespect me I go to a Super Bowl 91
the Giants against the New England
Patriots the New England Patriots missed
a field goal but you know what the New
England Patriots missed that day they
missed her and that was I think
Belichick was still the coach of the
Giants that oh wow oh God it was 91 when
Scott Norwood mixed the field goal you
have to watch that game to understand
check and see if Belichick was a giant
coach in 91 just just for my own sanity
just to surround it to the people at the
house understand what I'm trying to talk
about here you insane
saying it was Ray Hamling of the Giants
yeah in other words assistance what's in
here I don't think malechek wasn't in in
New England still I still thought it was
Parcells and he was a disciple of
Parcells so I wasn't sure but anyway
when you one things things well what I'm
still the first assistants it's really
funny when you watch that game in 1990
the giant saalu gotta use a tissue the
Giants
couldn't beat New England if they wanted
to ten years over it's like when the
Giants beat with when they beat the
Denver Broncos dad Phil sings at the
quarterback and if Phil Simms 123 for 25
but if Phil Simms good hit 23 people and
a whole [ __ ] decade never mind this
ball
oh do you mean the season I like the
Super Bowl in 1981 so is the 1990 season
could that be whatever the hell will
bill Varley the Giants okay play the
Giants Parcells was the coach in 90
unbelievable do you mean anyone I deal
whatever the Giants led the New England
Patriots and he missed the field goal
the guy was gonna shoot oh that was the
Buffalo Bills I'm sorry yeah was it was
90 so yeah belcheck was an assistant
coach like the giant yes okay if you
watch that game I know I'm not [ __ ]
yet thank God I don't all right hand me
was the coach I knew if you watch that
game no the Giants couldn't beat knowing
that a quarterback I think Jeff
Hostetler
that guy couldn't even pass a ball
couldn't even pass a ball it was a head
knowingly could have beat them a
thousand times but you know how the
Giants beat them they didn't give me the
ball networks that's how much they broke
it down this is way before the sign
stealing and the helicopters are camera
I mean pilot checks like NASA
this guy's got drones with you know he's
got a lot of tricks he's got a lot of
tricks but this is this is the advantage
of woman isn't it guys
he's not he's cheating but when winning
becomes that much to you that's a
problem but that's a complete different
episode I'm trying to talk to you right
now about that Super Bowl because that
Super Bowl watching that suit while I
was still married I was still very
unhappy I think the tethers were all
over this family from Boulder who they
were both trying to be millionaires and
how they got nineteen [ __ ] kids and
the wife is still a car
well it doesn't matter and the husband's
a [ __ ] - they turned on me during the
divorce I never forgot use you filthy
[ __ ] they were over the house for real
onion dip like normal Americans this was
way before hummus before suicide bombers
and people getting blown up blown up and
this is you know this is what America
was America and [ __ ] the Giants
played New England the Super Bowl and
they beat him with a guy named oj
anderson that was a 36 year old running
back Wow and what their objective was
was to run out the clock take this much
time as they could in between plays and
let this guy run three yards at the time
three yards at a time three yards at a
time they changed the offensive line
three yards of the time put in another
skinny black guy let him 1 1 yard Oh Jay
take a breather three more and then
little beat them you like Joey your
[ __ ] point how many times was the guy
run for three yards a thousand times
they took the ball away and they but
what I'm going back this they had a plan
for that game Dan a plan for that game
when I ate the dick with Netflix on the
way home I made a plan for my podcast my
stand-up and my personal life and I
stuck them to the best of my ability and
I'm reaping some of the rewards some of
them you can't be you know if you go for
four and you get three out of four you
can't complain he got three out of four
it's like I told we we and I were
talking about a weight watch it diet my
goalie first of all the diet isn't the
diet it's called the lifestyle change
it's your lifestyle change it's not a
diet diets are ugly worth diet is the N
word of health
don't use diet it's a lifestyle change
instead of eating that piece of toast
I'm gonna eat an apple instead of
drinking that smoothie
drink water it's a lifestyle change but
we're talking about out a particular
thing about the weight watch is how it
worked
how teaches you to like make deals with
yourself make deals with yourself you
know like I'll do this and I won't do
this I'll do this and I won't do this
it's kind of the same thing you know I
don't even know what the one thing I
wanted to talk to you about and not to
disagree with you but at the beginning
we're like don't be alone cuz I've been
alone on a lot of holidays and like
these people who are working tomorrow
today and then they'll be alone or maybe
they move somewhere new I I definitely
see what you're saying how we're talking
about on the last podcast where if you
have some mental health it's not good to
like isolate and I agree with that but I
think there's some people who like
almost like I'm looking forward to
spending a day and you know going over
my notes or just doing nothing for a few
argue to me sometimes enjoy that no I
haven't alright you don't want it so
long you could sit Adam I don't mind you
waking up at 9:00 I'm looking for you
know it's jerking off one time and maybe
hanging this bag of clothes that you
don't need and getting it ready to take
it to the [ __ ] Salvation Army on the
26 maybe taking your time taking a
shower but you know what take care
yourself
the worst thing scenario go to Denny's
get the 4x4 diet go out see the beauty
that there is out there I know some
people like to be alone you're talking
to the person that invented being alone
you're talking to somebody who's no
leech out you had a brother and you like
being alone think about somebody who's
raised being alone I love being alone
yes they had a prime example yes they
had not much on the plate it was Monday
what I needed to do was lift eye lift
every Monday at 10:00 with a trainer and
I had nothing else to do I mean my wife
is going to Universal we were running a
bunch of things nobody really knew this
is no school this week I did what I had
to do I went and lifted I
I made 15 calls 15 emails I had and the
[ __ ] a few people whatever but
then I forced myself to get the hell out
of the house because I know I'm gonna be
an ass all week
I'll be announced all week it's
Christmas I'm not going at it and they I
forced myself to call down to the Comedy
Store Thursday night and don't get me
wrong if Christmas Eve Christmas night
things ain't going good well there's a
midnight showing uncut gems I will be at
the family store Christmas night tonight
just sitting around to watch calmly I
try to get on stage but I'm not there to
step on some of these toes some of you
always cancels on Christmas right
because they realize they went somewhere
and had two cocktails some less they'll
be six but sometimes they'll just pull
an open mic up there on Christmas oh
geez about to go yeah because nobody
shows up down there so depending on how
I feel tonight I might shoot down there
that's just the way it is I didn't call
in for it I'll definitely be down there
tomorrow night then I got Colusa
Thursday and I don't have oh yeah they
opened up some tickets for San Francisco
so if you want to go this is the chance
to get you tickets right nine well you
know what I'm below for Christmas
grandma gave you your 50th savings bond
if you train it in you get $21 who cares
about the 30-year growth you ain't got
time for that stuff anyway you know I'm
saying what I'm trying to say to you is
this plan be grateful for what you have
don't worry about what you don't have
it's Christmas Day you do the best you
can
there's no use crying over spilt milk at
this point over the year the year is
done the year is done and gone and it's
never gonna come back again you know
what my cats are never gonna come back
Netflix is never gonna give me another
special there's a thousand things aren't
gonna happen but you know what 2020 is
coming and I know there's gonna be a
good year for you guys and for myself
whether it's Bob willingness whether
it's I know Hubbs is having a hard time
up there I know a thousand of you guys
that you know Scott Cunningham I want to
congratulate you on the birth of your
new child all right I'm watching
guys I'm watching and I'm saying Lord
Rosen cars still supporting after all
these years I'm watching you guys and we
still got a tight-knit family this is
more than a podcast this is a state of
mind and this is two people who have no
reason we do all our communication
online and you believe that and you
believe that we do all the communication
online and then I come to your hometown
you shake my hand and we take a picture
and we move on for the rest of the
Melissa today is not the day to worry
about what happened three months ago
today is not the day to worry about what
happened six months ago today is not the
day that what happened to worry about
what happened 20 years ago what happened
I acknowledge it and make the best of
what the day is it's Christmas it's
Christmas
I don't know these is born today I don't
know if it Porto Ricans showed up I
don't know what happened I'm not here
the chronolock long but whatever the
world is chronologic eyes Christmas of
what it means and sharing you know what
you broke you don't have money to give
nobody gifts that's fine I smile and a
hug just does it just does just as well
a smile the hug will get the same
response as giving somebody a wallet a
tie you were gonna wallet maybe we knew
your wallet and you felt worse than what
you already did you know or a bad gift
no no gift is a bad gift but i'mma tell
you what's always a good gift
a handshake the looking an eye and
telling somebody you love them thank you
for doing what you do you know what's a
good always a great gift a hug and just
saying hey man I remember what you did
for me this year you made me laugh at my
roughest time that's the best that's a
Christmas gift that never ever fails a
handshake telling somebody you love them
and giving them a hug and going hey this
is what it's all about the end of the
week I wanted to buy your helicopter but
my funds were short I'm barely making
rent I'm saying if I wanted to give the
gifts that I wanted to the people I
would need I'd be homeless there's
people that deserve great gifts is here
but you know what they're gonna get to
get to my friendship and that's the best
gift you could ever have and the gift
that you're gonna give me by listening
by you know taking little notes by
whatever is to give to your friendship
that's all you need to worry about this
Christmas tonight when you're eating
dinner or when you're not even gonna
look around you
see what you have and see how good you
really have it you will see we're waking
up this morning feeling bad about
yourself you [ __ ] you got 2020 make
the best of it write down your goals and
go for it that's it I know you're
successful I know you have a job but I
also know and actually you wanted to
play the ukulele and put a wig on
backwards and sing like Lady gaga I
never told anybody
yeah no you don't need to tell me how I
know your deepest secrets
let's see you lurking outside of gay
bars thinking what's gonna happen I go
in there with this little virgin ass but
they take a chance Columbus did 2020s
around the corner you're gonna hear from
us next week we'll do a couple podcasts
for you we're not gonna leave you out in
the cold New Year's Eve and during the
week so we will definitely be back like
I said I got a couple tickets open for
ya for San Francisco we have Fresno we
have Bakersfield in January and we also
have the second show added at the
tabernacle theater and the Atlanta
Georgia which I'm excited about
get to go hang out with Gladys Knight
stand on line and eat some whatever the
whole black slow food and I'm ready to
go you know I'm saying I show up onstage
with a big dick and a fro and a picture
of black panther it was the last time
you showed up with a picture of black
panther before we leave real quick I
want to thank our sponsors the minimum
with us since day one
I want to thank on it on it com has
always been there for us since day one
you understand me
why because I believe in them and they
believe in us me as far as I'm concerned
alpha brain is the way to go why
because they give you a hundred percent
money-back guarantee and they don't even
want the product back that's class
that's American that's what I'm talking
about you want to start a new year on
the right foot alpha brain you want to
workout you want to have a little bit
more confidence shroom tech shroom tech
sport you get on planes you travel you
get on plane you get on trains you get
an uber
what's the uber mutt when you gotta get
on there with six people everyone else
uber pool this is for you shroom tech
Emil avoid the flu avoid all this thing
wash your hands this is the time of the
year so do me a favor you want to get a
kettlebell a 25 pounds to start doing
little Hobgoblin squats and farmer walks
you want to get club bats to give
yourself a little bit more flexibility
in your shoulders a little strength in
your wrists on it has it all we've been
together for seven years and listen I
still do all their products whether it's
the protein bar the mint chocolate
whether it's the ICT with coconut cream
or for your coffee my wife uses whether
it's the protein on it is the way to go
but now that they have the lottery
ticket get the Alpha brain you guys are
gonna lose you wouldn't have experienced
all be markets personally it takes you
for that really good barbecue plays you
train at the haunted facility on it's
doing great things
what I'm trying to say is go 200 that
calm right now press in church and get
10% off your first order delivered to
your house also manscaped the best and
below the belt grooming it's Christmas
time it's Christmas Day and your [ __ ]
helmet looks like Santa you got gray
hairs at least I do but not really why
because I manscaped they've created the
only tool you need to shave your nutsack
sand the area bound around the pole of
love it's called the lawnmower 2.0 you
have no idea there was tons of anxiety
for years I didn't even take a look down
there
I don't even shave it you got to shave
it it looks like it looks like the you
Bhama you understand me that's you dick
looks like the Unabomber so stop it
clean it off clean it trim it give it a
little sideburn give it a little Nazi an
exclamation point whatever be creative
place one order and take care of
everything you need why because they
have something called the perfect
package you get the low more you're
gonna pair of empty chafing boxes that
won't scratch your sack plus they're
gonna throw in the crop preserver or
deodorant for balls and the Reviver a
sprint that tones and refreshes your
junk and keeps you cool it's like the
CGI package they used on the Irishman
your balls are smooth with the perfect
package you'll be as smooth as a snowman
you understand me so do me a favor you
want 2020 to start a new thing you want
to get on tinder you want women to do
dirty things with if you show up and
you're not trending you're not prepared
where they gonna think you only got 10
minutes to make a good impression
maybe your face ain't right maybe it did
you missing a tooth
maybe that bad breath or won't they see
that you expect and it's all trimmed and
they see the love and that stick of debt
and those nuts ashamed and they'd look
like like an Arab when he's neatly
trimmed you know I'm saying like they
like the little points they're gonna say
this is what we're going for baby boy
this guy he's taking care of his dick
and it starts with manscape and
manscaped also makes a big a great
Christmas gift
like I said place one order and take
care everything with the perfect package
now the church get 20% off your first
order when you use promo code church at
manscape calm or the perfect package and
with promo code Church CH you are CH and
then they'll throw in a free travel bag
that has a little zipper inside I don't
need to tell you what to do with it
that's manscape calm use promo code
church for 20% off your first daughter
gets manscaped and keep you gots clean
you understand me
listen I'll see you guys in San
Francisco
if not we'll talk next week we're gonna
rock your world I love you guys with all
my heart I want you to remember what I
said
be grateful today with what you have and
what you don't have because maybe what
you have you don't need anyone sometimes
it's better to want then to have I love
you guys thank you for supporting the
podcast wanna thank the [ __ ]
I want to thank myself for showing up
here Monday and Wednesday but I wanna
thank you guys for being savages and for
always having my back I love you guys
have a Merry Merry Christmas hug your
families and have a great safe day check
this melee